I talked about playlists a lot because
it's full of randomest I like his
playlist like I'm the first time we hung
out I know I've said this story before I
was so shocked I was like is this Duran
Duran I was like wow like you have like
the most random playlist so it you're
totally country obviously but you have
like a pretty broad everything yeah you
have a really broad playlist so to find
out why Blake loves some of those random
songs we came up with a little game
because I know he loves games called I
just bring my friends here and make them
do stuff they don't want to do it's
called celebrity playlist shuffle
[Applause]
alright so here's how it works
okay I hit this button wait a minute is
this the same piece of crap that you
want to offer some money you wanna be a
sponsor for this the first season is
this on the world television right this
is a big show can you get renewed for
another season we did but we don't have
them where's the I brought you some you
brought me a gift
that's time yes okay what is it yes L
can you please bring it this is
embarrassing I come to help them come
when I sleep
[Applause]
this is the new and improved Kelly
Clarkson stupid game
whatever game that your that you make
your friends play lights up as long as
you have to be uncomfortable on this
show playing your weird games now you
actually have Locke and nice podium this
guy look here rearview mirrors you do
that deal where you know like a soldier
is going to surprise a family member but
it doesn't work because the kids like oh
my god there's that don't work now
holders I like that like beer pong but
favorite because every time you use this
I want people to know I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this